Speaker 1: Hey, this is a really strange video.
Yesterday, radical Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene, visibly struggling
to breathe on the floor of the House, ranted
about mask.
Now you might be saying, David, hold on.
Are you saying masks or masks?
I'm saying mask.
She was ranting about mask.
I don't know why she was saying mask.
Singular, she was.
Everything about this video is very, very
strange, and look at the amount of disinformation
she packs into just a 90 second rant.
Speaker 2: Georgia seek recognition.
Speaker 3: Mr. Speaker, I'd like to address
the House about how children feel about Mask
Speaker 2: Geneva,
Speaker 1: suspend how children feel, how
children feel about mask, what
Speaker 2: the gentlelady is seeking unanimous
Speaker 3: consent unanimously addressed to
address the house for one minute
Speaker 2: without objection.
Gentlelady is recognized.
Speaker 3: Thank you, Mr. Speaker.
I'd like to talk about how children feel about
mask.
Speaker 1: What now?
I know that a lot of the stuff she does is
her accent and people say, David, you shouldn't
really talk about that.
Like when she says mental as opposed to mental,
that that's her accent.
But does that include?
I want to talk about how children feel about
mask.
That doesn't seem like an accent that just
seems bizarre.
Speaker 3: You see, while they're watching
television since Super Bowl games where adults
are filled filling stadiums without mask,
Speaker 2: and it's
Speaker 1: why is she out of breath?
I mean, just none of it makes sense.
Speaker 3: Join themselves while they see.
Concerts happen, they see people go to work,
they see adults going many places all over
this country without mask.
They are forced to wear a mask every single
day at school.
Speaker 1: They they are forced to wear a.
All of them.
Speaker 3: And it's wrong.
Actually, it's child abuse.
Now I know that sounds like strong words,
but it really is because children are not
at risk of COVID 19.
Speaker 1: Now that is a lie.
That is a lie.
The truth about kids and COVID is that when
the pandemic started, it did seem kids were
less likely to contract it.
Remember, that was the big thing and that
if they did, they had mild illness.
But as the pandemic has progressed, that has
changed.
It's still true that most kids will have only
mild symptoms, but most people who get COVID
have mild symptoms.
We are seeing more and more children's hospitals
across the country with surges in pediatric
COVID hospitalizations.
We have seen some specific conditions that
are side effects of COVID that seem to almost
only affect children.
So it's very much this whole thing about kids
don't have to worry about COVID is very much
untrue.
Speaker 3: Filtering are at the lowest risk.
But do you know what's harmful to children
having their faces covered all day long at
school, not being able to see each other's
faces, not being able to see their teachers
faces, not being able to learn properly speech
emotions and having that connection, seeing
each other's faces and learning from adults
seeing each other's faces.
Speaker 1: This is sort of like you didn't
read the book, and all of a sudden the teacher
calls on you to tell us what was in yesterday's
20 pages that we were assigned like this.
She seems very unprepared for this in more
ways than just the heavy breathing.
Speaker 3: Now, while Democrats are going
on with the masks for they and not for me,
kids have had enough and they're going to
be future voters and they are sick and tired
of being forced to wear masks.
It needs to end.
Masking children is child abuse.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, masking children
is not child abuse, but anybody who's been
paying attention knows that the masking is
ending.
First of all, the kids don't really seem to
mind the masks that much.
I think I mean, the masks more more than the
kids, to be perfectly frank.
But the masking is ending.
The masking is anything we've heard from New
Jersey that they're going to end the masking
in schools.
California is moving in that direction.
New York is talking about it.
We're clearly moving, rightly or wrongly,
into the endemic phase of how we are accounting
for this virus and the masking is ending.
And again, why is she out of breath?
Why is she saying mask singular?
We may never know.
You can see this clip if you're just listening
today, we'll have this clip up on our Instagram,
which you can find at David
Pakman show.